[Música]
bolivia ojo es el único país del mundo
donde la popular cadena de hamburguesas
mcdonald's sin lugar a dudas uno de los
símbolos de la globalización ha quebrado
tras poco más de cinco años de
operaciones sus ocho restaurantes en el
país tuvieron que cerrar sus puertas en
2002 porque simplemente los bolivianos
pasaron de ellos
[Música]
vamos que casi podemos decir que para
muchos hoy bolivia es algo así como la
aldea de astérix y obélix un rincón del
mundo que se resiste contra viento y
marea a lo que esta misma gente llama el
imperialismo cultural de la
globalización y las grandes potencias
occidentales precisamente el presidente
boliviano evo morales un claro exponente
de esta forma de pensar su hostilidad
hacia todo lo que tiene que ver con el
capitalismo alcanza tan nivel ojo que se
jacta de llevar más de cinco años sin
tomar un solo vaso de coca colá compra
cocacola y echa a la taza del baño pasan
minutos y ya está destapada está tras
haber daño pero bueno más allá amigos de
este tipo de historias anecdóticas lo
cierto es que el discurso de evo morales
es uno de los más beligerantes contra el
libre mercado la globalización y los
sistemas políticos occidentales
el vivir bien o el buen vivir como dice
nuestro hermano presidente de ecuador
eso es la síntesis del socio libro
comunitario
vivir mejor es la síntesis del
capitalismo hay una profunda diferencia
de hecho a día de hoy casi podemos decir
que evo es el último líder de ese ciclo
de izquierdas que dio comienzo a
principios del siglo 21 y que hasta hace
muy poquito ha dominado la política
latinoamericana me refiero a líderes
como hugo chávez y maduro en venezuela
kirchner en argentina
lula y dilma en brasil o por supuesto
rafael correa en ecuador
[Música]
de todos ellos a día de hoy sólo
sobreviven liderando la política
nacional de sus países
evo morales y nicolás maduró claro que
en circunstancias muy diferentes
mientras en venezuela el desastre es
prácticamente total el país casi ha
quebrado bolivia ha sido durante los
últimos tres años el país que más ha
crecido de toda latinoamérica
[Música]
esto ha hecho que evo prácticamente que
conserve intacta sus altísimas cotas de
popularidad y reconocimiento
internacional al tiempo que para muchos
seguramente también muchos de vosotros
se ha convertido en el gran referente de
la izquierda que en sus propias palabras
aspira a terminar con la globalización
imperialista dominada por las grandes
multinacionales el resultado es que para
muchos empezando por el mismo evo
morales- de su líder indiscutible un
ejemplo a seguir antes los políticos
iban a estudiar a harvard en eeuu en
lovaina en bélgica ahora vienen a
estudiar nuestras políticas y se las
llevan para otros en cambio no es más
que un líder populista que está
cercenando las libertades civiles y
conduciendo a su país al desastre pero
cuál es la verdad cómo está realmente
bolivia ha logrado de verdad
evo morales- el boom económico que se le
atribuye estas son algunas de las
preguntas a las que vamos a contestar en
este vídeo pero antes de nada echemos un
vistazo atrás a la historia para que
veamos dónde comenzó todo
la gran crisis boliviana y las reformas
bolivia amigos es un país increíblemente
rico en recursos naturales oro plata
estaño y hierro gas natural petróleo e
incluso litio muchísimo litio y ojo
porque este es uno de los recursos
naturales más cotizados en nuestros días
habéis oído hablar del salar de uyuni es
impresionante océano de color blanco que
atrae a gente de todo el mundo en busca
de una foto perfecta casi propia de otro
planeta pues mientras esa brillante capa
de sal que cubre su superficie se
encuentra una de las mayores reservas de
litio del mundo para que os hagáis una
idea a día de hoy las reservas estimadas
de litio de bolivia tendrían un valor de
mercado de cerca de 80.000 millones de
dólares casi tres veces todo el pib del
país y a todo ello hay que sumar el
resto gas petróleo oro vamos un
despliegue impresionante de riqueza
como dicen también en perú este país
está sentado sobre un trono de oro a
pesar de ello amigos de visual polític
bolivia es hoy y ha sido
tradicionalmente uno de los países más
pobres de toda latinoamérica fijaros a
inicios del siglo 21 prácticamente antes
de ayer el ingreso por habitante de
bolivia era similar al de la república
democrática del congo con todo podemos
decir que los 80 fueron la década más
dolorosa tras unos convulsos años 70
dominados por continuos golpes de estado
y regímenes militares que endeudaron al
país hasta las cejas y destruyeron
prácticamente cualquier actividad
productiva la caída del precio del
estaño que por aquel entonces era la
mayor exportación del país hundió a
bolivia en una crisis brutal
hola
por si fuese poco la respuesta del
gobierno de izquierdas de la unión
democrática y popular que lideró el
presidente hernán siles suazo fue tan
mala que el país cayó en una
hiperinflación descomunal de más del 25
mil por ciento en apenas unos años y
retrocedió atentos 30 años en términos
de desarrollo baste mencionar que
cuantos ileso ha subido al poder se
pagaban 230 pesos por dólar cuando
terminó su gobierno se pagaba un millón
149 mil 354 pesos por cada dólar ojo
hasta 2008 bolivia no recuperó la renta
media que tenía en 1977 ante este
desolador panorama el gobierno convocó
en 1985 apenas dos años y medio después
de tomar el poder
elecciones que esta vez llevaron a la
presidencia a víctor paz estenssoro que
ya había sido presidente en tres
ocasiones anteriores primera tarea que
va a emprender el nuevo gobierno es
poner freno al proceso de crisis que
está viviendo el país vamos a
enfrentarnos a la crisis
de ese momento y durante prácticamente
toda la década de los 90 los diferentes
gobiernos bolivianos y sobre todo el
encabezado por el presidente sánchez de
lozada pusieron en marcha reformas muy
importantes impulsadas por cierto por el
fondo monetario internacional y el banco
mundial que perseguir estas reformas
pues fundamentalmente amigos dotar a
bolivia de una economía competitiva de
mercado así que en estos años se
sucedieron las privatizaciones se
liberalizaron muchísimos aspectos de la
economía se trató de combatir el déficit
fiscal se redujeron los aranceles el
estado en su nuevo rol será excluido de
las labores productivas y de la
inversión financiera directa
concentrándose en crear las condiciones
para permitir el funcionamiento de los
mercados suena bonito verdad el problema
es que las reformas no consiguieron
superar ni la corrupción ni el
capitalismo de amiguetes es verdad que
se lograron muchos avances la economía
se estabilizó y creció una media del 4
por ciento durante todos los años 90
pero claro esto era insuficiente para
sacar al país de la pobreza
desde luego era un crecimiento muy
inferior al que registraban muchos
países emergentes por ejemplo en asia
sin seguridad jurídica y sin competencia
poco había que hacer es decir me explico
no es que los planteamientos fuesen
erróneos ni muchísimo menos el problema
fue que la implantación que la puesta en
marcha de esta reforma fue simplemente
horrible por supuesto como ocurre casi
siempre cuando se reforma algo tiene un
coste social por ejemplo muchos mineros
y campesinos minifundistas perdieron su
trabajo y se vieron obligados a emigrar
a las ciudades
[Música]
pero claro la falta de resultados
visibles generó muchísima frustración
social por así decirlo hubo muchas
promesas y pocos resultados y tal vez os
preguntéis cuál fue la gota que colmó el
vaso pues en este caso no fue
responsabilidad de bolivia sino de sus
vecinos las crisis de brasil y
argentina- de principios del siglo
acabaron por derrumbar cualquier signo
de prosperidad el país exportaba a estos
países y como éstos estaban pasando una
crisis brutal bolivia no se quedó atrás
entre 1999 y 2003 la economía boliviana
no creció nada
un país tan pobre incapaz de crecer algo
falla verdad el modelo no puede ser
bueno
el movimiento cocalero y el movimiento
indígena bolivia ha sido siempre tal vez
muchos lo sepáis un gran productor de
planta de coca que tradicionalmente en
los países andinos se utiliza como goma
de mascar y también para hacer
infusiones sin embargo esta planta
también tiene un uso digamos mucho más
lucrativo la producción de cocaína la
droga ilegal que más dinero mueve de
todo el mundo pues bien en los años 80 y
90 y eeuu ya se encontraba en plena
guerra contra las drogas y presionaba y
pagaba a los gobiernos latinoamericanos
para que destruyeran los cultivos el
problema es que esto implicaba dejar sin
trabajo y arruinar a decenas de miles de
familias
[Música]
eso es precisamente lo que ocurrió en
bolivia muchos campesinos vieron cómo el
gobierno iniciaba una guerra contra los
productores cocaleros y destruía sus
plantaciones así que ya os podéis
imaginar
el cabreo monumental de esta población
[Música]
qué es tener un negocio que generaba
mucho dinero solo en 1986 las ventas de
cocaína igualaban a todas las
exportaciones legales del país desde
luego los campesinos cocaleros no se
quedaron de brazos cruzados se agruparon
en sindicatos y recurrieron a una
continua movilización manifestaciones
cortes de carretera bloqueos pero esto
no es todo aún hay más en bolivia la
población de origen indígena que es casi
la mitad del total estuvo
tradicionalmente excluida del poder
político es decir de facto bolivia un
país muy racista pero no con una minoría
sino contra la mayoría de su población
de locos
bien así que ya tenemos los tres
factores claves que impulsaron al max al
movimiento al socialismo el partido al
cual pertenece ivonne morales que por
cierto era el instrumento político que
desarrollaron los sindicalistas
campesinos los representantes cocaleros
fundamentalmente crisis y frustración
económica guerra contra la coca y
racismo precisamente estos fueron los
pilares de un partido el más
y arrasó en las elecciones de 2005
obteniendo una inédita mayoría absoluta
que no sólo mantuvo sino que incluso
incrementó en 2009 y en 2014
[Música]
los resultados de cebos morales
la primera gran medida de evo fue
nacionalizar el sector de los
hidrocarburos y lo hizo además a lo
grande ordenando al ejército ocupar los
yacimientos de gas aunque lo cierto casi
siempre hay una historia entre
bastidores es que más allá de las fotos
lo que se hizo no fue sino renegociar
los contratos de explotación conforme a
una ley que ya estaba aprobada antes de
la llegada de eeuu pero bueno el caso es
que el gobierno boliviano con las
reformas multiplicó la renta petrolera
es decir lo que recauda con la
explotación del petróleo y el gas
natural el gobierno pasó de llevarse
algo menos de un 20 por ciento a más del
80 por ciento de los ingresos justo
además en un momento en que daba
comienzo el llamado super ciclo de las
materias primas y los hidrocarburos que
multiplicaron sus precios
[Música]
y esto es todo por si fuese poco en 2005
poco antes de la llegada de evo al poder
tanto el banco mundial como el fondo
monetario internacional decidieron
condonar la deuda externa que bolivia
tenía contraída con ellos de un plumazo
el país se liberó del 35 por ciento de
toda la deuda exterior y claro estos dos
factores fueron auténtica gasolina para
los gobiernos de evo morales que
contaron con recursos públicos como
nunca antes había tenido el gobierno de
bolivia en cierto modo esto explica la
evolución tan positiva que ha tenido la
economía boliviana durante estos años
pero abajo del ojo es verdad que el
gobierno de evo morales ha hecho cosas
relativamente bien por ejemplo de todos
los gobiernos de izquierdas en
latinoamérica que antes hemos mencionado
ha sido el más prudente a la hora de
gastar de hecho ha reducido la deuda
pública y ha acumulado ahorros
importantes también ha apostado mucho
por la inversión en un país que
prácticamente carecía de toda la
infraestructura y ha contribuido
enormemente a la cohesión social con la
integración de los pueblos indígenas
bueno
él mismo es un animal
pero un momento antes de cosa balance
sobre mi espera porque la historia no ha
acabado aquí una cosa es que haya hecho
las cosas mejor que los gobiernos de
chávez maduro correa o kirchner y otra
muy distinta es que las cosas se hayan
hecho bien es verdad tienes de que está
en el poder el país ha crecido una media
del 5% cada año y que la pobreza se ha
reducido a la mitad pero claro es que
cuando los precios del petróleo y las
materias primas cayeron empezaron los
problemas el país es más dependiente de
los recursos naturales que cuando evo
morales llegó al poder y eso desde luego
no es algo positivo de hecho hoy en
bolivia las importaciones son mayores
que las exportaciones el déficit público
real del gobierno en 2016 pudo superar
la friolera del 8% la inversión privada
es muy muy reducida y según el business
es uno de los países de todo el mundo
donde más difícil presenta hacer
negocios
fijaros en nueva zelanda un país que ya
sabéis que nos encanta solo se requiere
un trámite para iniciar un negocio y se
tarda medio día en hacerlo el coste es
ridículo en bolivia en cambio son
necesarios 50 días 15 trámites y ojos 7
meses de los ingresos promedios de
montar una empresa de verdad alguien aún
piensa que haciendo tan complicado
montar empresas y negocios un país puede
prosperar nuestros antepasados a quien
llevan aquí no conocieron la pobreza la
pobreza es producto de la colonización y
de los modelos de desarrollo económico y
social implantado por los países
capitalistas y luego está también el
problema del narcotráfico
[Música]
y ojo que nadie se lleve a engaño
bolivia sigue siendo hoy uno de los tres
países más pobres de sudamérica tal vez
todo esto junto a la aparición de
sospechas de corrupción ciertas promesas
incumplidas la poca confianza en la
justicia que ha promovido y algunos
gestos como éste el enorme ego de evo
morales inaugura un museo sobre su vida
propiciaron la primera gran derrota del
más en 2016 en febrero se llevó a cabo
en bolivia un referéndum que tenía por
objetivo cambiar la constitución para
permitir que evo se presentase a un
tercer mandato consecutivo y ganó el no
aún así parece que bo sigue empeñado
reelección debemos morales vuelve a
polarizar bolivia bueno tú qué piensas
cuál es tu pie sobre el gobierno de evo
morales crees que llevó a qatar a la
constitución y se marchará a su casa o
tratará de aferrarse al poder
espero que este vídeo te haya resultado
interesante si ha sido así y quieres que
hablemos más de bolivia de evo morales y
de otros políticos latinoamericanos no
te olvides en darle al botón de like
para hacernos
y por supuesto si aún no lo has hecho
suscríbete al canal un saludo y hasta la
próxima amigos compra cocacola y echa a
la taza del baño pasan minutos y ya está
destapada la taza del baño
[Música]